the 70 class of nvidia's gpus have
always been exciting to me because
they've always represented The Sweet
Spot in terms of performance in terms of
value and also in terms of power
consumption and today we're going to see
if that story continues with the new RTX
4070 and personally I think there is a
lot riding on this card because 4080 40
90 pretty Overkill pretty expensive and
40 70 TI to a lot of people was just not
that impressive and I mean on the
surface things are looking pretty good
the founders Edition card is super
Compact and it's basically the same flow
through design as the 4080 and 4090 with
fans on both sides but in a much smaller
two slot form factor in fact the new
4070 is the exact same dimensions as the
3070 like one to one completely
identical now I'm not going to tell you
to upgrade from a 3070 to a 4070 but
it's at least nice to see at least one
of the 40 series gpus is nice and
compact what is also the same between
these two gpus though surprisingly is
the amount of Cuda cores 588
of course it's not exactly one-to-one
but you just don't usually see that we
almost always expect an increase between
Generations GPU clock speeds have seen a
pretty massive jump though plus 43 there
and we do see a nice bump to the memory
spec as well 12 gigabytes of gddr6x
basically it's not identical setup to
what you'll find on the 4070 TI total
board power though just 200 Watts for
the new 4070 which is pretty nice but
what isn't so nice is that price
increase six hundred dollars is not
exactly what I would call mid-range now
look accounting for the huge inflation
that we've seen since the launch of the
30 70 500 back then is kind of you know
not too different to 600 today but of
course Nvidia definitely has the
financial buffer to keep this thing at
500 bucks the problem is that they don't
really need to because there's no real
current gen competition at this price
point at the moment and at 600 us it is
200 cheaper than a 4070 TI which I think
we'd agree is pretty substantial so
let's fire this thing up and take a look
at performance and I wanted to
experience you know first hand what
you're actually getting here so I booted
up some popular Esports titles that I'm
pretty familiar with and ran through
some matches I mainly wanted to see
whether the 4070 would be suitable for a
1440p 240 hertz or even 360hz experience
and yeah it is pretty much there in
OverWatch 2 with medium settings I was
seeing just below 400 FPS during fights
no problem there at all with the GPU
running below 200 Watts so total board
power here is 200 Watts but it's by no
means capped at that limit valorent was
no problem at all as you would expect
500 FPS plus there when paired with the
ryzen 5800x3d and in this case actually
the 4070 was barely pulling 120 watts
something a little bit more demanding
though Apex with low settings seemed
solid enough for a 240Hz experience but
you will notice some dips here and there
in the more open areas during fights and
stuff like that overall though pretty
decent considering that this is 1440p
and the power consumption seemed much
lower than I had expected at just 150 to
1 60 watts here so in a nutshell roughly
the performance here that I'd expect
from a 38 similar but the power
consumption was easily 100 Watts lower
but let's try something a little bit
more demanding how about the new
overdrive Ray tracing mode in cyberpunk
this mode severely ramps up the amount
of rays in any given scene as well as
retracing just more of the total scene
in general so here we're at 1440p high
settings with the ray tracing crank to
that new overdrive mode and the game
looks absolutely insane in terms of
lighting but at barely 30 FPS however
when stacking both the dlss balanced and
frame generation we actually get a
playable experience depending on the
scene usually hovering around 80 FPS
that lighting though is absolutely
ridiculous everything looks so much more
real NPCs don't look like they're made
out of Play-Doh anymore and the shadow
is basically everywhere looked so much
more accurate so yeah very surprised
that this actually works so I mean in
isolation at least the new 4070 is
actually looking pretty good like decent
capable performance at 1440p power
consumption below 200 Watts as well it's
really nice to see but of course let's
compare it to some more gpus and see
exactly what we're working with so I had
already run benchmarks for the 2070 and
3070 in the new Last of Us Part One and
I was pretty familiar with the huge
generational increase that we saw there
but between the 3070 and the new 4070
it's just not the same we're looking at
slightly over a 50 boost here from the
2070 to the 3070 but then only another
25 to 30 to the new 4017 so nowhere near
as dramatic of an increase for this
generation in f122 basically the same
thing 1440p High settings here you're
getting a pretty good experience no
matter which of these three gpus you're
playing on to be honest but there's
definitely much more of a substantial
increase between the 2070 and 3070 and
mind you that's technically at the same
MSRP the margins did look much better in
Modern Warfare 2 though here the 470
managed to Gap the 3070 by 50 which I
will admit does turn out to be an
outlier but for such a popular game it
is pretty good to see so first of all
let me just say if you have a 30 70 or a
3060 TI the experience is actually
pretty similar here on the 4070 it's at
least within the margin of toggling off
a few graphic settings here and there
but what about versus the 4070 TI well
in Hogwarts Legacy at 1440p we're
looking at about a 20 boost here with
the ti but that's for spending 33 more
money 800 versus 600. so from a value
perspective the new 4070 actually beats
the ti in this specific title but is
that what you should do I mean the 470
TI it's likely the biggest competition
for the 4070 at the moment that 200
price difference it is substantial don't
get me wrong but it's also within the
range that you could probably justify it
if the card is substantially faster so
testing across 12 games at 1440p with
high to ultra settings here's what we're
looking at between the two for the most
part 20 to 30 FPS differences some games
that Slims down to around 10 in control
and Modern Warfare 2. feel free to pause
this chart if you're interested in the
specific FPS values but here's what we
really want to see the green bars here
show the performance multiplier of the
4070 TI over the cheaper 4070 and on
average I measured 18 so again 18 more
performance for 33 more cash not exactly
one to one and so that does make the
4070 the better value option it's not an
enormous difference after all we're
talking about two gpus on the same
architecture that just released back to
back but for the new 4070 it is giving
you slightly more for the money in fact
an interesting comparison here is versus
the 10 gigabyte RTX 3080. the
performance is almost the same the
margins can swing a few percent either
way depending on the game but on average
I found that to be just a 0.1 percent
difference between the two now if you're
one of the lucky few that actually
managed to buy a 3080 at its 700 MSRP
I'd say your GPU aged pretty well only a
100 difference here over two years
that's not bad in reality though
considering the 3080s market price was
realistically Beyond 900 US during Peak
demand the 4070 isn't looking terrible
in my opinion now here's a broader look
of how things shape up in f122 versus
the previous 70t gpus like the 2070 and
3070 the rest of the 40 series lineup as
well as the code of gaming gpus the 1080
ti so the 4080 and 4090 are pretty
overkill for this game at 1440p
especially when you consider that dlss
is an option here that we have not used
and so overall the 4070 is looking okay
for those that are on a two generation
upgrade cycle you're getting almost half
the latency and double the frame rate
between the 2070 and the new 4070. the
4070 looks particularly decent in Modern
Warfare 2 though for whatever reason
hard to imagine that a 4080 here is
double the price now you're probably
wondering what amd's answer is in all of
this and according to them it's the
6950xt yeah a previous gen GPU they've
completely tanked the price of their
previous Flagship and the price to
Performance is actually pretty good and
at the moment there are plenty of 6950
XTS going for 650 bucks or less and you
are definitely getting more frames here
versus the new 4070 AMD have gone
absolutely mental and they're probably
hoping you have too for thinking that
this is actually a fair comparison
because make no mistake while you are
getting a faster product most of the
time the 4070 wins in pretty much every
other category looking at performance
per watt here there is a massive
difference the 4070 pool is just 190
watts in F1 whereas the 6950xd chugs
well over 300. there are also some games
where the 4070 does manage to squeeze
out a lead believe it or not cyberpunk
is one of those few examples and that's
multiplied even further when Ray tracing
and dlss are brought into the picture
and besides amg's cone gen Hardware is
already out there so why are we talking
about a previous gen GPU we should be
talking about the 7700 XT here not a
6950 XT alright so the 4070 you know in
closing it's pretty good in isolation
you know it plays pretty much anything
that you'd want at 1440p and it's
especially good if you value a smaller
form factor card with a lower power
consumption I mean having a 30 3080
performance in a sub 200 watt card I
feel like there is genuinely something
of value there of course though if
that's not something you care about then
at the 600 price point you also have AMD
6950 XT if you don't mind buying
something that's last gen and pulls way
more power and of course is a much
bigger form factor and if you're also
someone who might be considering the
used market then actually buying a used
RTX 3080 might be a genuinely good deal
yeah that's pretty much it as always a
huge thanks for watching of course I
will leave it linked down below for
those interested and I'll see you all in
the next one